[Music]
you're the voice of the enemies tonight
I am the voice of tonight let me hear a
little bit
hello I am Jermaine Fowler uh it's not
that I'm gonna do my real voice nope do
the the MV voice but I mean why don't
you do it like Entertainment Tonight so
why don't you say it is Entertainment
Tonight you at the Emmys but in your
Emmy Jermaine voice right this is
Entertainment Tonight
I'm Jermaine Fowler at the Emmys
they only hired me to be myself so
that's the best this is the best job
ever I don't do anything but just talk
like this I like it now it's gonna be
all live right say what if you like
screw up a little bit or something um
well if I screw up I screw up whose name
are you the most nervous about oh my god
well you know what phonetically I've
been pretty conditioned to know
everyone's name you know so there's no
one's name that I am nobody trips you up
maybe the honors and the Anna's that
trips me up
the only thing right I don't get it I
think it's I don't I don't know what it
is on a ferris not Anna no I've known
Anna Anna as that's been instilled in me
I've known I'm important I've been a fan
of on Affairs since I was a high school
so I that's fine that's fine
in Anna Kendrick Anna Faris okay Anna
Kendrick on Affairs that's it's not
Steven Colver if Stephen Colbert I know
that one I know Colbert it's it's that
one's easy Destiny's you want thank you
that'd be really bad be said you know
like the host said Colbert he was funny
he's the only name that's not
phonetically spelled out for me so it
was easy to mess up that be an easy one
screw up
yeah I did be mad you'd be upset about
that you're kind of funny if you did
though yeah I mean yeah I mean eat on
this he's a comedian he'd get it ugly in
it I think he'd get it I get it
you know what I'll take her to port Hey
look I've been called Jamal and Jerome
and Jeremy my entire life so you know
two minutes that's all that's all it's
all gravy so you got a series coming up
yeah I do we have second season of
superior Donuts coming out October 30th
on CBS
[Music]